c'est cette fois ci
mais qu'est ce qui se passe là ma taille
aux
pompiers ont la la la la vous êtes là
vous c'est sa part angers les choses
j'ai jamais vu autant d'agitation dans
l'île aux enfants mais portait pas ne
nous restait plus on est de fous plus on
rit françois françois qu'est ce qu'il ya
au pardon bonjour je ne vous avais pas
vus excusez moi avec tout le monde qu'il
ya aujourd'hui
extrants soit excuse moi de te déranger
mais l'heure est grave ouh la la quel
ton tragique casimir qu'est ce qui
inquiète ce n'est plus possible il faut
faire quelque chose je viens juste
d'être bousculé par une patinette qui
m'a fait un verre à la pâte à quoi la
houle ou la cour la patinette m'est
rentré dedans j'ai un verre mais le nom
est tu veux dire un bleu mais non tout
le monde sait très bien comme j'ai la
peau orange qu'on le bleu et d'orange
café du verre
pour casimir tu es bien à plaindre
j'ai trouvé une solution une solution
why alors et de fait bien attention
casimir ça ne réussit pas toujours
d'avoir des idées non mais là je suis
sûr de ne pas me tromper je vais poser
des panneaux de signalisation a très
bien née es tu sûr de connaître tous les
panneaux du code de la route ah ouais
enfin
de toute façon je vais très bien me
débrouiller tout seul je vienne coire
beau faut que je m'en aille à tout à
l'heure casimir oui françois n'oublie
pas de respecter les panneaux à quand tu
reviendras voit aussi whatwg a aussi
bon ma malle magique où est ma malle
magique
nous me l'apporté un bon les amis vous
voulez m'aider à à sortir et à
reconnaître tous les panneaux de
signalisation
ouais bon on va se mettre là
voilà
bien
donc on évitera les embouteillages et
les accidents comme ça alors ça qu'est
ce que c'est
bon sens interdits tiens bruno tu le
prends
celui là vous connaissez
croisement oui mais si un croisement de
deux routes semblables ouais voilà tiens
voilà
à un autre là qu'est ce que c'est c'est
encore un croisement
ouaya ya une grande là une route
prioritaire d'une route ouais enfin oui
une grande route et une petite ya
laurent
tu poses anneaux
s'est enfin ça c'est facile un stop stop
on s'arrête
enfin michel tient
ensuite on mettra celui là aussi il y en
aura besoin
oui des changes de tourner à gauche
tiens ben ali
un autre
voilier ressemble au 1er mai la flèche
et et dans l'autre sens un oui tiens
tu le prends vous voulez poser ainsi
vous embarrassent à un autre intéressant
c'est qu'il est marrant
défense de doubler c'est tout
voilà
organe est encore un dernier là
ça c'est mon panneau personnel ben oui
sinon je me ferais écrasé voyons tam tam
tam à la brave dame d'amour adam tam tam
tam bas
et voilà allez les enfants je vais vous
donner des balles au
grand soir interdite par la bombe on
passe par là donc ça fait rien interdit
aussi là pour aller faire dérailler le
kiosque venez venez venez
annonce françois qu'est-ce que j'ai
parlé à gauche regarde on peut pas les
interdits ah oui effectivement bons
ballons passent par la mildt a fait rien
interdit à droite au maintien non
vraiment qu'il admire si c'était
nécessaire d'en mettre autant mme awa et
alors enfin avec tous ces panneaux on
pourra jamais vivre tranquillement oh
non je trouve ça très pratique
et bien pratique essayons
françois oui oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya qui
me vient m'aider je ne peux plus sortir
regarde je suis entouré de sens interdit
kesy b
pas des nouveaux parole et il te plaise
boire fondée par lyon oui bah évidemment
sont pas des caramels mous
dit dans ta danse ça progresse très bien
regarde j'ai trouvé un nouveau pas avant
c'est bien bon suspens
quoi c'est un pas de danse mais c'est un
très joli pas de danse arbon
dit françois oui à propos des ballons à
ils sont très beaux je te remercie
casimir tiens quelqu'un à acheter des
vieux papiers sur la pelouse c'est idiot
de salir notre jardin ouais je trouve ça
scandaleux
oui si on laisse les gens jetaient des
papiers dans les halls et ça va devenir
un véritable dépotoir c'est vrai mais
j'ai une idée dont grâce à ma
merveilleuse malle magique mais plus
personne ne jettera de vieux papiers
avant tu vas angers secte est magique
voilà casimir tu vas voir ta balle
magique
et voit la
défense de jeter des papiers sur la
pelouse très bien casimir et maintenant
les gens vont les jeter dans les allées
c'est vrai et oui à temps
voilà
défense de jeter des papiers dans les
allées ça c'est très bien qu'ils aient
myrmidon c'est un petit peu dangereux de
laisser cette pancarte en plein milieu
de l'allée si quelqu'un fait pas
attention il risque de la rt se faire
mal c'est vrai tu as raison je vais
arranger ça comment
regarde
voilà
la
décence de ne pas faire attention à la
tente car tu écoutes casimir c'est pas
très sérieux de laisser toutes tes
pancartes comme ça n'importe comment le
remède est pire que le mal casimir les
gens vont vous pas pouvoir avancer non
non ce ne sera pas du tout casimir c'est
pas au prince je crois que tu as raison
non oui alors à temps
voilà
interdit de poser des pancartes
quasi mai
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
pourquoi vous avez mis des pancartes
partout juste flou
interdit de poser des pancartes
défense de feu de ne pas faire attention
à la peau kurt mais c'est complètement
farfelu votre truc parfois lui casimir
chercher un moyen pour empêcher les gens
de gâcher la beauté du jardin où je
tourne des vieux papiers partout mais le
résultat n'est pas très fameux voilà
alors vous l'at il vaut peut-être mieux
que j'enlève mes parents car oui oui
faudrait mieux
[Musique]
c'est papier c'est moi qui les ai mis à
sécher comment casino c'est toi qui
achetait ses vieux papiers sur la
pelouse tu as dû tout fait ces aléas les
tuent les ramasse en vitesse mais non et
pourquoi parce que je n'en ai plus
besoin ces papiers crb a enveloppé
l'écrin qui m'ont servi à écrire les
penta et j'ai plus près ah oui bon les
goûts de tout ça ça ça m'est
complètement égal casimir il ne faut pas
laisser des vieux papiers traîner sur
les pousse à l'est les ramasse tout ça
allez hop bon d'accord
alors attention tous les papiers up ici
allez
hop les toits il y aurait stone hop
[Musique]
voilà
ça alors que siné
[Musique]